today on stick to football it's 2020
barely but we're gonna talk 2021 we're
gonna draft our top five prospects for
2021 because we're crazy we're gonna
have some fun we have Kenny
willikers coming on the show the pride
of Michigan State gonna talk to him
about getting a Senior Bowl invite if
you are watching on YouTube and I hope
you are I'm in a stick football hat
trying to promote the the new hats that
we have we're gonna be giving them away
at the Senior Bowl in the combine so
come see us there Conner is in like a
tie-dye shirt that does I mean his arms
are gonna explode and my man Melo hope
you don't know Melo is mr. Melo by day
he's a teacher I just want you to
explain your outfit so they have themed
weeks it's homecoming week yeah at my
school and today was where your favorite
sports team or the mahomes Jersey but
also I come straight from school to the
podcast and I did not bring a shirt to
change into so I don't usually rock a
Jersey unless I'm tailgating but today
special occasion
Connors doing it to Connor he's got my
home's over shoulder this is a Chiefs
podcast today apparently which I know
that people want but we we actually have
guys a ton of things happened I thought
that we would like oh the Natty's over
like take a break breathe a little bit
and then here's where let's start at the
national championship game let's just go
back after the game I got excited I not
like LSU's like an adopted team for us
and I was excited for you to burrow and
had Oregon and everybody and so is Odell
Beckham he actually went there so my man
gives out literal hundred dollar
handshakes which you know we do on the
show to congratulate good players the
problem is some of these guys still had
at the time
eligibility an ESPN and everyone else in
the world with a camera is captures
Odell handing out hundies which first
LSU is like now they're fake and then
they were like yeah we're looking into
it well on Thursday a police officer has
pressed charges against Odell for
slapping him on the ass in the locker
room after the game you check your BR
app there's video of it so a lots going
wrong here fro Dell this week
I don't like I just think you got to be
a little bit smarter than some of these
things
I mean adele is harmless I think in
these situations he's trying to have
some fun the cop was in there like
making sure guys weren't drinking and
telling people to put cigars out I do
think he's the literal fun police guys
but this is the world we live in
it's his job if it happens on camera
it's going to be a big deal yeah and it
sounds like he's gonna get charged with
simple battery and much like probably a
lot of our listeners I was like what the
hell does that mean so I went right to
our guy Pat Chamberlain who by day is
Patrick Chamberlain Esquire it sounds
like this is just gonna be like a one
thousand dollar fine at most he could do
some jail time but it's gonna be a slap
on the wrist it sounds bad because all
the media outlets are putting it out
there that there's a warrant out for
OBJ's arrest it's not gonna be a big
deal
talking with Pat I don't even think that
this thing goes through a fine pay a
fine at most if it doesn't get dismissed
yeah I don't think this will be a
lingering issue now you know I wouldn't
recommend doing something like there I
see so many people taking sides here
like drawing a line in the sand and
saying like of course he deserved this
like he hit a cop and there's people are
that are just like let him have fun and
it's like well you know yeah it's great
to have fun the cop was doing his job
it's stupid that they were they were
giving the kids such a hard time it's
ridiculous but I'm sure he had orders to
go do that and you definitely shouldn't
just touch a cop just don't touch him
just do whatever you want
dance yell I don't care it's just like
everyone loses here but this really
won't be that big of a deal when all is
said and done that's the most important
thing doesn't matter I'm setting myself
up to so many okay boomer comments here
but I'm more bothered by what felt like
Odell trying to steal the spotlight from
these kids who just want a national
championship game like I get being
excited and wanting to be on the field
but like let her for net wasn't out
there Jamaal Charles wasn't out or
Jamaal Charles well Adam he wasn't out
there it's fact you're like all those
like LSU greats they weren't out there
where's Glenn Dorsey like he wasn't out
there you know so it's like that's more
like it I get it I'm an old man but for
me it was like come on Odell like I'm
okay with him being out there and
celebrating I didn't
get the vibe of oh let's make it all
about me I mean he's out there giving
the guys hundred-dollar bills aren't
more doing the hundred-dollar handshake
so I don't have a problem with it but
you do have to be smarter because you're
gonna get your university in a lot of
trouble now
I don't even if those guys don't have
eligibility anymore they did when they
were taking the hundred dollars so will
the players get in trouble no not at all
well LSU get in trouble you bet your ass
they're going to something's gonna
happen with it they're gonna have to
report it they already did to the NCAA
to the SEC but you can't do it it's an
impermissible gift you can't be handing
out money they're gonna get in trouble
so OBJ's gotta be thinking about that
there's a kid who who grew up in the
town that I lived in for a long time and
he's playing d2 football was and I
remember one saying like yeah if you
want like you want to come I'll buy you
lunch and we could talk about football
he's like he actually can't buy me lunch
something as simple as me buying a kid
lunch because of my job he was worried
would be against n-c-double-a rules like
that like I've known this guy since he
was 12 years old I can't buy him lunch
so same c-double-a we called me see
double [ __ ] for a reason and
hopefully they're not listening so that
happened but most importantly today as
you're listening to this is the deadline
for players to enter the 2020 NFL Draft
there's a three-day window for players
to change their mind we've actually
already seen one person do that Kyle and
he'll changed his mind he's going back
to Mississippi State after declaring
back in December another player going
back to college and this is a huge one
Najee Harris and I believe Connor that
we talked about this on the Wednesday
show that I've been hearing that he was
really having a hard time with this
decision and now he has decided to go
back to Alabama so Nick Saban has done
some good recruiting internally he gets
dvanstaa Smith back and he gets Nagi
Harris back as well as Alex Leatherwood
so the the core group for Alabama next
you get your left tackle your running
back and your wide receiver coming back
not bad
oh and Dillon knows this and Roberto
linebacker no not bad at all I mean I
look at this now she had been leaning
this way for a long time it's really not
surprising I think he would have been a
top 50 pick I believe when all is said
and done so doesn't mean the decision
was an easy one but it feels like he was
you know easily convinced to come back
to school for a year they have a good
core they're still
Alabama so when you look at Leatherwood
coming back Smith coming back and now
she coming back those are three
important pieces of an offense and this
is an Alabama team that is hungry I mean
let's be real they're looking at it and
very disappointed in this season where
the the same energy we saw this exodus
from LSU where it was like okay won
national title some of the guys said
there's no better way to go out I'm
leaving school now and going to the NFL
Alabama they haven't had that feeling
this year so there's definitely an
emptiness that they want to fulfill and
and go back and give it one more run in
this running back class for next year
it's actually starting to shape out to
be partly weight would Nagi Harris I
think he's gonna lead the pack so far I
don't want to get too far ahead of
ourselves here but I like that decision
because right now if I'm looking at next
year he's the number one back in that
class now for this year he would have
been like number four number five for me
same with Kyle and he'll if you come out
this year you're gonna get lost in a
pretty deep running back class a chance
to go back
I guess prove that you can catch the
ball with Mike Leach there as your coach
there's gonna be very exciting for them
but to come out next year same with
Chuba Hubbard where we don't have a
whole lot of proven running backs or at
least we didn't until earlier this week
so now with those three guys kind of
leading the pack there's a lot of hype
around their name Chuba Hubbard rushed
for 2000 yards and getting your receiver
back bringing back another young
quarterback I think that Oklahoma State
is in a great position as well as you
know obviously Alabama yeah I mean that
they are and I think for both those
teams and there's gonna roll right into
both those teams have to feel pretty
good about where they stack up in their
conference next year and that's because
there has been an exodus at LSU guys
would you expect the team wins you
expect some poaching I've never seen
anything like this before Joe Brady the
passing game coordinator gone to the
Carolina Panthers Dave Aranda the
defensive coordinator now the head coach
at Baylor they've also lost seven as of
right now underclassmen in addition to
seniors Joe burrow and Christian Fulton
so you lose grant Delpit patrick queen
clyde edwards a layer justin jefferson
lloyd cushion berry Sadiq Charles and
Jacob Phillips oh and we haven't heard
yet from Kayla van chase on
LSU's depth chart is going to be
depleted heavily next year compared to
what we saw this year guys and I know
they thought that they could lose 10
Jacoby Stephens announced on Wednesday
night he's gonna go back to school he's
the only one like he's the only guy
there keeping so we could still hear a
couple more guys leaving LSU but I've
seen some exodus --is in my day this one
has to take the cake it's like the old
Miami days when they used to do this
year after year they'd have a lot of
guys leave I do think that LSU has a lot
to worry about if you're one of their
fans Jamar chase coming back so gonna be
huge Myles Brennan at quarterback who
looks like he's going to take over that
job you losing a lot on that offensive
line though you're losing Justin
Jefferson you losing your running back
and that defense is gonna be depleted as
well
LSU looking to repeat next year they're
gonna have their hands full I mean the
good thing is for LSU they're 2019
recruiting class was you know a top
three recruiting class they had four or
five star players so if you're looking
for them to turnover fill these starting
spots as we saw with Derek Stingley this
year but him being that more of an
outlier that's a good thing for LSU
they're getting top to your talent in
there right now it's only getting better
and just means that these underclassmen
are just gonna have huge rolls earlier
than expected which I'm sure a lot of
them are very excited for I think for me
more so than the players guys right now
is them losing some big-time coaches
yeah I think yeah you lose Joe Brady you
lose Dave Aranda you can recruit it's
harder to get those coaches and I think
for a door Garron who is one hell of a
recruiter that's the hard part here and
I know speaking to some people
internally at LSU it I mean it's no
secret that no I talked about openly on
the show I've been asked often time to
consult with players and on some of
these guys I straight-up told him you
need to go back to school
Sadiq Charles our left tackle he was
suspended for six games this year guys
and now he's going to the NFL Draft
probably not the best move I think he's
gonna be awful lot of teams boards
because of that six-game suspension it's
reportedly rumored to be a failed drug
test I don't think we're trying to
confirm or break any news here and I
also think you have to fail a lot of
drug tests at LSU and I don't want to
just talk [ __ ] on LSU because Texas is
the same way you got to fail a lot of
those before they start handing out
suspension six games is like one like
that's the old Holton Hill yeah your one
game yeah and then it was like okay four
games six games such a big one fixes
probably you can't pass a test it's not
that you failed one and that is kind of
it's alarming and so I would say looking
at this from a draft perspective the
guys that I think I don't say anyone
made a bad decision because you can test
you can work your way up but Sadiq
Charles from what I've heard from NFL
teams is a late day three guy off a lot
of boards and I think Jacob Phillips is
the other one who came out early as a
linebacker I think he's probably around
four guy who is athletic he's got a
great you know it looks body beautiful
but instincts aren't really there I
thought if he'd gone back with Michael
divinity graduating with Patrick Queen
going to the NFL it would be Jacob
Phillips linebacker room next year give
him a chance to blossom a little bit I
think now in this in this class you know
he's gonna get a lost a little bit yeah
I think so too but when you win the
national championship and you're one of
the best teams in college football a lot
of these guys are gonna go ahead and
jump ship especially when your
quarterbacks leaving already with Joe
Burrell even as a senior I think a lot
of these guys are trying to strike while
the iron's hot
I don't know that your draft stock is
going to get much higher next year I
mean if you know Derek Stingley if he
could come out I think you would if
Jamar chase could I think he would too
but luckily for college football fans we
get them next year at LSU we get Derek
Steven playing some receiver next year
yeah I mean that's what the Heisman uh
Vegas is saying oh really oh that's
right the odds yeah up came out yeah so
it's gonna be exciting I do want to ask
you guys we don't have to do a deep dive
into this because we don't know a whole
lot yet but what are your initial
thoughts I wrote about it so people can
check that out in the app what are your
thoughts on Joe Brady at making the jump
to offensive coordinator this fast in
the NFL
not just in college I like it I think
that at LSU I don't know when he was
gonna get that time to actually be the
coordinator and much like we're seeing
with these prospects strike while the
iron's hot if you're a coach this
offense was historically great you had a
quarterback throw in the SEC for 60
touchdowns
if Miles Brennan comes in next year and
shits the bed he might not have this
opportunity to go to the NFL so Joe
Brady
he's like what thirty years old already
gone from you know grad assistant to
offensive coordinator
in the NFL I think in two years time
this guy could be looking at head
coaching jobs
I completely agree this was a great move
for him obviously I'm sure he got a ton
of money I think it was rumored that LSU
was willing to more than double his
salary which would have got him near the
million dollars per year mark but listen
David Tepper down there throwing money
around to get the right guys and I think
for the Panthers it's gonna be hard to
judge this hire after one year because
this is gonna be a kind of a turnover
year for Carolina we don't know what
their quarterback situation is gonna be
we don't know exactly what this team is
gonna look like so I'm willing to give
it some time but if you're taking a
swing for the fences I love going after
a guy like Joe Brady there to work under
Matt rule I know you guys love hearing
my conspiracy theories on this podcast
are you ready for this one Joe bring
Matt it Matt rule David Tepper they're
building a new facility I think they
tank for Trevor next year I think they
should I don't know if they yeah can I
can't see Matt rule tanky and Hyneman or
even really Dave pepper either what but
what that is curious though what are
they gonna do at number 7 do they try to
get a quarterback in there this year are
they happy with Kyle Allen for another
year maybe they bring back Cam Newton
and think I saw enough Kyle Allen well
speaking of that one of the quarterbacks
that they could try to make a play for
Toa is gonna be healthy by April
according to his agent which means we'll
be able to throw it's supposed to be
about a 40-minute throwing session where
he'll make 680 throws a pro day exactly
to me guys this is colossal because I
think if all things go well from here on
out for tua I think he's gonna be the
third overall pick no matter what and
it's just a question of if the Lions are
gonna trade it and who they're gonna
trade it to so my whole scouting
notebook Friday morning is about that
who will trade up to number three
overall here's one thing I just want to
play devil's advocate here this report
came from to his agent the day after the
national championship game I'm just I'm
playing devil's advocate I like Leigh
Steinberg we have a good relationship
with them but doesn't that timing seem a
little curious like oh yeah two will be
healthy in April like Lee knows what
he's doing
he he literally wrote the book on how to
UNH
like this either they sat on this and
released it that timing was intentional
or they're just this is his job is to
keep his player's name in our mouths and
they've done a very good job of it if
it's accurate and I hope it is no one in
the world could be more rooting for -
other than this podcast because we loved
this gentleman from the moment he came
in a half-time for Jalen Hertz huge - of
fans I want this news to be true I just
feel very skeptical about it's like what
what prompted this because his doctor's
visit was two weeks ago before he
declared so like where did this come
from
I guess well I think it would be really
hard to walk it back though and be I oh
I actually know he's not gonna throw in
April because if he doesn't throw in
April it's gonna be now he's thought
goes down that's what I'm saying like I
just wonder yeah so I think it's got to
be true I think there's some facts
behind it and it's coming from his agent
so I think he has to throw in April even
if he's maybe not 100% ready if he's
still sitting around 75% we're gonna
have to see him throw that football or
he's not gonna be in play I think the
report said that he would be healthy and
I like they use the word will be nothing
I said healthy yes yeah four months
recovery yeah and I hope I hope you went
to the doctor in New York and they were
like man yeah everything's good there's
blood flow because that was the doctors
we talked to that's kind of what they
said was like well if there's not blood
flow that's what you worry about but you
are right Conor tua if he is healthy in
April and we'll know because the combine
rechecks are in early April if he's
healthy this changes the NFL Draft and
again my home you can read my article
this morning Scotty notebook in the VR
app but it is basically about the teams
that have the ammo to get to number
three because we've said it before it
will be Jo burrow it will be chase young
the draft starts at 3:00 Bob Quinn
should be smoking one of those LSU
cigars right now thinking about how many
pics he's gonna get whether it's Miami
sending five and 26 or you know the
Colts who have some extra picks in round
two whoever I think there's gonna be a
bidding war to get to number three right
now just like a couple years ago the
Colts had three didn't need a
quarterback well actually they did they
just didn't know it yet and so they
trick it out imagine if they just stayed
Pat took Sam Donald the whole would've
felt differently we all set right now
III think you're right though and it
seems like Detroit is a team that needs
to trade down and they're looking for
partners so I know that we mock draft
and we don't do the tree
ADEs maybe we will eventually but I
think that this Detroit pick is gone I
wouldn't be surprised if they're already
shopping it they probably want to get
their hands on a guy like Jeff a CUDA or
Derrick brown and you can move down and
get those guys and I think Miami is
definitely gonna want to jump and and do
the trades you don't want somebody like
the Chargers the Panthers jumping up in
front of you with Detroit so I think
Detroit is moving that pic and obviously
it seems like Miami is gonna be the spot
that does it this is one of those moves
that you can really rebuild your roster
with it I mean you look at the Tennessee
Titans who are playing this weekend in
championship weekend when they traded
out of a top pick and they got a lot of
players out of that deal this is the
kind of move where you can you can
really get an army of picks there
because Matt Stafford I hope he's
healthy I mean he's 31 years old if he's
healthy you're not really worrying about
the quarterback position right now I
know a lot of people have brought him up
as you know can someone trade for him do
the lions consider it to a but I think
right now Stafford who I think is a very
good quarterback they ride it out with
him and try to rebuild the rest of this
roster with a lot of picks yeah
absolutely there's a lot of intrigue
when it comes to the NFL Draft this year
all right let's take a break when we
come back we got our man Kenny will
ACCA's michigan state pass rusher
welcome back to stick to football we
have one of the best pass rushers in the
entire country Michigan State senior
Kenny will I guess the kitty let me be
probably not the first to congratulate
you but let me congratulate you man our
getting an invite to the Reese's Senior
Bowl we will be there as well and really
looking forward to seeing you against
the best offensive lineman in the
country yeah thank you you know invited
I was waiting for you know it's an
opportunity I'm excited about to go down
there and showcase my skills so you know
what Sam I'm really looking forward to
and I'm grateful for the opportunity so
I'll start off with asking you questions
and how much did you know about the
Senior Bowl before this season was it
something that was in the back of your
mind maybe after your junior year or
when did you kind of learn about the
Senior Bowl and get excited about it I
didn't know too much about it until my
teammate Carl Willis played in it last
year and that's when I kind of became
aware of it and I kind of saw how it all
works I followed him and I you know saw
how he did down there and I watch the
game and I pay attention to him so
that's when I kind of first
privy to the game and then thought bene
aware of this since then
Kenny obviously there's a lot of talent
down there a lot of one-on-ones a great
time to showcase your ability which
we've seen over these last three years
but who is the best offensive tackle you
faced in college football this year or
even the last couple of years I don't
know if he's a guy that gets a lot of
recognition honestly but I'd say rashon
Slater from Northwestern number 70 he's
always given me the most fits his I
thought so he had the best pass that and
you know he was able to recover quick
you had good feet and good hands so you
know I always felt like he was the
toughest matchup to go against her in my
career Kenny one thing that and I'll be
I like very transparent we cover the
draft very heavily here and headed into
the year it seemed like in terms of
draft conversations you were you were up
there's one of the top guys and you had
your most productive season in terms of
sacks and it felt like the conversation
dropped off a little bit is that
something that you pay attention to or I
mean you had ten sacks this year you had
15 and a half tackles for loss you
finished your career with 49 tackles for
loss twenty-three and a half sacks but
you're not getting to mention with some
of the other pass rushers in this class
I mean does that piss you off is that
something you're motivated to go down to
Alabama and prove everybody wrong yeah
most definitely I tried to buy into that
too much and uh you know I try to just
do what I do go out work and now you
know hopefully the results on the field
speak for themselves but uh obviously
coming into season I had a little more
hype than I do now and I had my best
numbers I felt like this viewers my game
I could obviously improve but you know
we don't get the same attention that I
was getting and my name slips and uh you
know draft process draft or a little bit
you know obviously I used that as a chip
on my shoulder but it's not waters that
I haven't been in before obviously comes
in as a walk-on it's something I'm used
to some people doubted me something I'm
used to so a little more motivation and
fires me up to play and see a bowl just
a little bit more this week so you were
talking about I'm gonna go back to
something because I just pieced
something together here we do cover the
draft and we're already kind of looking
ahead to next year you broke your ankle
against Oregon in the bowl game was the
tackle you were facing is that Sewell
number 58
yes sir yeah what do you think about him
I think he's a great tackle I played my
as a freshman and you could see that he
had all the tools to be great and then
I'd filed them but throughout this year
and you see that he just continued to
build on his game and improve his
technique and uh he's one of the best
tackles in the country Kenny now that
you know schools behind you you're
obviously getting ready for the NFL
Draft what's your day-to-day like right
now as you prepare for not only in the
Senior Bowl but the NFL Combine
interviews and all that stuff leading up
to the actual draft I'm on a pretty
strict regimen right now I'm actually
waking up at 7:30 which isn't really
that bad compared sometimes there that's
up for conditioning but you know waking
up at 7:30 going through a little bit of
a morning routine trying to read
something in the morning every morning
when I wake up make breakfast and I get
to the gym by 9:30 and then I will
usually go through some prehab so
warming up a little bit and uh you know
just talking about with my trainer you
know talking about things and life's
about becoming a pro you know the more a
little more the mental aspect of the
game of playing in the NFL and then you
know taking care of my business and then
we workout for two hours 10:45 to 12:45
and I do some post rehab stuff and then
I've been off for the day for the most
part after that other than a pretty
strict even schedule so I'm trying to
add a little bit of weight so you know
I'm eating
seven eight times a day but now I'm sure
my physician coach is flying into
getting ready for the Senior Bowl so
right after this I'm gonna go back to
the gym and uh you know work on some
positions work stuff with him now I have
so many things like comment on also
eating seven eight times a day not
trying to gain weight here just it's
just happening but you seem to read
every morning as the resident nerd on
stick to football what are you reading
right now I'm currently reading extreme
ownership by Jacko going have not read
that one oh I'm familiar with his work
his podcasts what else what skinny
willikers do off the field away from
football though it's changed a little
bit over the years
growing up I was a lot more wild we ride
snowmobiles ride four-wheelers go
snowmobiling you know pretty much climb
trees pretty much so you can do the most
dangerous thing
get away with it so uh obviously as I
played football now I gotta be wary of
getting myself hurt so I don't do that
on some off the field as much but you
know it's been a lot more focused as of
recently a lot more sitting around the
house and I would like but spent a lot
of time you know watching film starting
to read a little bit spend a lot of time
working out a lot of time hanging out
with family but you know when I am free
it has a lost time I like to be outdoors
so what's your income choice though I
got a first what do you say pardon me
what's your drink of choice
don't say water during the day no party
drink party drink yeah shut the vodka no
okay
good man there we go okay yeah Kenny one
thing I do come across was on your
Twitter you lived in an attic for two
years was this during your time at
Michigan State or before that I was
during my time so 2017 and 2018 I lived
in the Attic
it was actually uh when I broke my legs
I chopped up three flights of stairs
every day but my own little space
come on little room I didn't have to
kill a few bats up there brother than
that it was pretty nice so you are
definitely gonna ace your interviews at
the combine and the Senior Bowl I can't
wait for that what are you what are you
gonna say two teams next week because
you are gonna have some interviews it's
like speed dating so hopefully you're
ready for that but when when you talk to
teams I mean they're gonna ask you a lot
of crazy stuff but as far as scheme fit
you know do you want to play D in do you
want to stand up in rush court you
mentioned you you're putting on weight
but you're probably like 260 right now
265 so what are you what are you gonna
say the team's about where you're at
next year I want to play DN with my hand
in the dirt that's where I feel most
comfortable
obviously I'm willing to do whatever I
can stand up I can come off the edge but
I feel like I had to play best with my
hand in the dirt keeps my leverage low I
feel like I flows really good leverage
and so if they can keep my head in the
dirt deal with me
is there a team that I know you're gonna
be just super
happy with whoever picks you but is
there a team that you were rooting for
that you have a you know you're a fan of
or that you want to you feel like you
fit in that scheme that you want to get
drafted by I've looked around a lot I
mean there's a lot of honestly a lot of
places I'd be happy to go I'd really be
happy to go anywhere but I've been a big
fan of the Saints being able to work
with a veteran guy like Cameron Jordan
and I think it would be something that I
would like to do I've also the Broncos
would be a place I'd like to go Chicago
bears their storied defense so does our
prize top sorry but really honestly
anywhere obviously playing in the Big
Ten
you win against a lot of top-flight
programs I mean you had a stretch this
year where you get Ohio State Wisconsin
and Penn State in a row like that Kenny
who do you think you know the most
impressive guy in this draft class with
you was that you played against
throughout that stretch same question
I'm combines forms so I had I did think
about it a little bit and I'd have to
say JK Dobbins you know I'm just I've
has always been impressed with how he
runs the football he's always been and
impossible to tackle he's insanely hard
to tackle his balance and vision is
insane to me and then he just takes off
so you know I've really been impressed
with the other ones been impressed with
him I want to piggyback that who's the
best quarterback you face because you
know the big ten you know we don't talk
about quarterbacks lot but now you've
seen you know Dwayne Haskins Justin
fields trace McSorley like there's been
some good quarterbacks up there who's
the one that you were like I'm glad I
don't have to play him again I'd
probably just Enfield's
or shape or not shape Harrison I'm
Tricia McSorley you just said Trace
McSorley was very elusive she definitely
a lot of times I thought I had him in my
grass in the pocket you would dip out on
me and avoid me a lot so he was
definitely one of the more elusive ones
to contain any guys that you just hated
playing against because you thought
there may be a [ __ ] or [ __ ] talker
just anybody that you didn't like going
against maybe you had a little extra
motivation to hit him
not too many Indiana we got into it the
Indiana kids a little bit it was
actually funny
I ran another tackle down a big-time
media day and I was like oh yeah you
were talking [ __ ] to me during the game
obviously probably Michigan is that week
every time we play Michigan and so it
always gets chippy we don't like them
very much they don't like us so I'd say
Michigan is probably the most hated
rival is rush you know there's a lot of
years with Mark Dantonio and you know
you're gonna be moving on to a different
staff for the first time in a while the
NFL but what was that experience like
you know being coached by him now I know
a lot of guys are closer maybe with
their position coaches but what was that
time like with Antonio at Michigan State
those great know yours here that people
say Michigan State is a family
atmosphere you know and that was a kind
of the way it is uh
you know as you go through college and
you're mature and you go through the
things in the first couple years um I
was a walk-on and I was still had some
growing up to do and coach D would take
me up in his office you know send me
down and have an hour talk from me on a
random Tuesday afternoon just about life
and you know my faith and how things
were going in my life and yeah you don't
see a lot of head coaches do that to a
player and not not of just a player in
general brows just some random walk
walking on long haired walk on from
Grand Rapids Michigan and you take time
out of his week to sit down and talk to
me and I you know that's the way the
coaches all our coach Bullock came in
and uh you know he welcomed me and right
away I'm a really big fan of Coach Boyle
he helped me out a ton taught me a ton
and you know it's just kind of family
atmosphere they really care about the
players there I mean we are excited to
see you in Mobile we'll try to make our
way to the field to say hey to you after
practices but good luck go show the
Detroit Lions what they need in a pass
rusher you and Trey flowers be a fun
little team so good luck man we're
looking forward to seeing that chip on
your shoulder down there so have fun
with it and best of luck to you yes sir
thank you having me I appreciate it
Thanks we are back Thank You Kenny will
ACCA's thank you to Melo and thank you
to Connor we are still here our top five
for this week is way too early but
that's alright that's how we like to do
it at six football so our top five
players 2021
it would have been boring for us to all
just list Trevor Lawrence Jamar chase so
you're actually gonna get top 15 because
we are drafting this thing we have
compiled our own big boards
and I'm actually I'm gonna let Connor
pick because your team isn't AFC
championship game
my team is the NFC Championship Game
Connors a Jets fan and the Mets manager
had to resign on Thursday I was waiting
for it I was gonna say does my football
team bring you no no hope ever but now
my baseball team the manager I wanted
them to hire had to step down I get the
first pick here and it makes it so easy
for me because I'm gonna take Trevor
Lawrence so listen I know a lot of
people watch the college the national
title game and we're like you know kind
of complaining a little bit some people
are overreacting Trevor Lawrence Trevor
Lawrence is an amazing player he should
be the number one overall pick next year
he would be the number one overall pick
this year over Joe Barrow and he's just
20 years old and I can't wait to watch
him for one more year of college
football and hopefully get that second
national title under his belt well I'm
gonna let your second because my team's
gonna win the Super Bowl this year so
cuz you don't even believe that in which
team are you talking about or the
Patriots still in it they're out okay
I'll go next I'm fine with that I'm
gonna take the big left tackle out of
Oregon now I really like Sewell you
already heard our guy we'll just talk
about him I haven't seen a tackle his
size be able to move like that in a long
time I'm really excited to evaluate him
more and not just watch him play on
Saturdays when he is draft eligible and
as soon as we're done with this draft
I'm definitely gonna dig into him he'll
be one of the first guys that I watch
very excited to you how he plays yeah I
am too I love both these guys they were
the top two on my board we're doing a
snake order I hope because I'm putting
my two picks in but you guys know I love
the receiver position I was a really bad
one and and now it's my favorite thing
to evaluate so I'm gonna take Jamar
chase and I'm gonna take Justin Justin
Ross here almost adjusted fields let's
take Justin Ross from Clemson so Jamar
chase you saw him go off a national
championship game I know he's listed
like 61 200 pounds I'm calling [ __ ]
on that because he is yoked up they do
this thick he is powerful what he does
is a route runner what he does yards
after the catch is really really special
now I don't know what his numbers will
look like next year with our guy back
there Brent
a quarterback but I love Jamar Chasen
and Justin Ross I do feel like a little
bit has been overlooked and they really
featured t Higgins more because Derek
Singley jr. erased that side of the
field so Justin Ross wasn't able to have
much production in that game but
remember a year ago what he did against
Alabama and that defense Justin Ross is
still a very special player we're just
not talking about him a lot right now
because of the some of the other
superstars yeah I agree totally and I'm
actually gonna go to the defensive side
of the ball with Micah Parsons and I
will say disclaimer there's a lot of
stuff going on at Penn State so this is
subject to change but what I've seen on
the field of Micah Parsons has been very
special I think he was one of the best
linebackers in the entire nation this
year as a true sophomore so next year
evaluating him as a junior I do think
he's a guy that's going to come out a
big thumper at linebacker they can also
drop back and cover you don't get those
a whole lot even with Isaiah Simmons I
think there's still questions with what
scheme do you play him in how do you
play him you don't get those with Micah
Parsons he's gonna be able to play for
three middle linebacker three four
middle linebacker doesn't matter just
put him in the middle of the field and
he'll make plays I'm getting jealous
here sitting and watching Matt just take
all the great wide receivers off the
board so I'm gonna get in on the action
here and go at jaylen Waddell I think
Waddell you know maybe the target share
hasn't been there at times for him
because they are so ridiculously loaded
when you look at Jerry Judy Henry rugs
Devante Smith but I think when you look
at Waddell just that acceleration at
times is so rare and now him and Smith
is a wide receiver tandem it in a way
it's really good Smith's coming back
because Waddell won't always be you know
double-team non-stop and all the
attention will always be on him so I'm
excited to watch him next year and I'll
just keep the fun going with the skilled
players right now because I'm gonna go
with Shuba Hubbard here and I think Juba
would have had a really interesting
draft process because you know he's a
younger guy redshirt sophomore that
could have came out a track speed
legitimate track speed and I wonder how
you know how high he would have been
able to climb but I think next year when
you look at Hubbard the Heisman
conversation is gonna be around him and
as long as Oklahoma State can win a lot
of football games and I hope they do so
he gets the attention he deserves
Hubbard might be that first round
running back
yeah I definitely think he could too and
there is a lot of hype around his name
going into next year I'll stick with the
skill positions I'm going with rondell
more the receiver out of Purdue if
you're not familiar I really like his
game and the versatility that he brings
is he big no but I think he's thicker
than guys like Henry rocks I mean he
really has built like Tyreke he'll he
runs like Tyriq Hill and if he is
healthy going into next season I think a
lot of people are gonna be very excited
about him you look at what he did as a
freshman at Purdue I mean he set the
world on fire one of the best athletes
I've seen in college football just find
a way to get the ball in his hands he's
like a Percy Harvin type guy Tyreke Hill
I think he's gonna be a very good
receiver prospect yeah I mean I like I
was it run down boy do you worry cuz
he's small he's hurt so they say like is
this another Hollywood Brown but he was
still first-round pick so even if it is
that then then it's not too bad I'm a
little surprised that this player made
it back through to me but I'll jump on
here Justin feels at quarterback and I
want to put a huge disclaimer on this
that we've seen one season of him and
that the season was nearly perfect in
the COS well playoffs he took a step
back through two picks and that game to
Clemson so I do want to see what he
looks like next year but I think headed
into the summer of the offseason already
pretty excited about Justin fields you
know what what he brings to the table
his size
his accuracy he brings a little bit to
the table as a runner so I like just
appealed I don't think there's a chance
for him to pass Trevor Lawrence in my
opinion but he is I mean I think he's
cemented in at QB too so I got Justin
fields there up next I'm gonna go with
Sean Wade so two Buckeyes for me at
corner Sean Wade really thought he was
gonna come out this year and decided not
to as a redshirt sophomore but Ohio
State has become corner you at least if
not DBU so I think you can look at going
back to hell you go back to you know Eli
Apple and Gary and Conley and those guys
and it's just been Marshawn Lattimore
it's just about one corner after another
every year they got a first rounder this
year is Jeff Okuda who's one of the best
corners we've ever seen Sean Wade's
gonna be a really good player next year
yeah and I'll stay with the corner
position I'll take my guy Patrick certs
hand the corner out of Alabama he's a
big physical corner I think that he
could fit into that minka Fitzpatrick
maybe they play him a little bit of
safety going into next year but I really
like what I've seen so far in his first
two
obviously has the pedigree to play
corner he's at Alabama he's been a
starter for two years already next year
be his third year starting I think that
he is a guy that could challenge to be
this number one corner in this class and
you guys just took both the players I
wanted as I needed someone on defense in
my top five so I'm just gonna go full
fantasy football here quarterback Jamie
Newman he's going to Georgia I think
this will be a really good opportunity
for him to showcase how talented he is I
mean obviously playing at Wake Forest
there were highs and lows but you just
talk about traits he's got them all and
I think he'll be able to take some huge
jumps next year I don't know if he'll
find his name into the you know the
Justin fields category most definitely
not the Trevor Lawrence category but
everybody's got to be watching Newman
next year and to round this out this top
five someone that we talked about
earlier on the show because it's a
little bit of a surprise he went back
would have been a top 50 pick this year
Najee harris now she could do it all he
runs with power he runs his speed he's
got good vision and most importantly he
can catch the ball we've seen him go up
in High Point the ball we've seen him
make things happen after the catch he's
great at the second level of the
football field
I love naxi Harris around out my top
five yeah before nagi harris decided he
was going back to Alabama I had him come
to Steven Jackson I was very excited
about him that his size and what he can
do catching the ball maybe even like an
Arian Foster guy well I really like
Knology excited to see him hopefully
next year at the Senior Bowl my next guy
though won't be at the Senior Bowl I'm
going with Amon raw Saint Brown that is
a mouthful but the USC receiver I think
is gonna blow up next year crowded
receiver room this year with Pittman
with Vaughn Pitman at least will be gone
I think that he's gonna step up and be
the number one receiver had 77 catches
in that offense getting Keaton slobo
school and I really think that Saint
Brown is gonna be a guy that can explode
and have a huge junior season at USC I
like it
we'll see what happens with we're still
waiting for their other receiver to
clear blonde on to the skinny what
that's the skinny one like everyone
knows exactly that means
all right ending this thing I'm gonna go
defense again a player that I think a
lot of people forgot about because we
haven't seen a plane a year that is
Dylan Moses linebacker at Alabama for
the knee injury he would have been a top
five or six player for the in this class
for me he's that good we'll see
where he is next year but I love dill
Moses you you got us on you know talking
about linebackers and trapped on draft I
just gave way that we recorded how to
order oh well but I really really like
dill mostly she's gonna be up there with
some of my favorite linebackers I've
evaluated as long as he can get back to
full health so those are our top fives
tweet at us at stick to football leaving
you're our apple podcast review if
there's someone we missed or if you just
want to argue with Connor cuz he gets
the email when you leave a review hey
five stars for Connors here alright time
for a little draft on draft let's jump
right into it dirt shingle berry he'll
the name I know you say you play Isaiah
Simmons on defense but is there a
specific coordinator or defensive scheme
you guys think he would thrive under I
mean I think again any I think it's just
where you put him in those schemes now I
don't know if you look at Robert Sala
where you would put him a weak side
linebacker and I think that's probably
the most common answer I don't
necessarily want him in the middle of
the field playing middle linebacker I
want anymore at weak side where he's a
little more off ball and is able to be
in most defenses your weak side guys
gonna be your playmaker I think he just
fits that mold so well that's why the
Giants pick makes me nervous with
gentlemen they're in the way that he
likes to use his linebackers gentlemen
makes me nervous bringing in maybe that
Patriot scheme and using him in
different ways I would like that but I
don't know what we're getting with the
Giants the team that I have been very
intrigued by would be the Chargers at
six they probably don't need a
linebacker but we're just talking to
scheme I think the Chargers are one team
that would say we're gonna use him all
kinds of different ways just like they
did during when James they had him
playing linebacker some I think they are
a team that would utilize Isaiah Simmons
they would put him at safety they'd
probably still play him at nickel corner
like [ __ ] Clemson's doing so I think
that they would actually take advantage
of everything that he can do and use him
like the weapon that he is yeah I don't
think I haven't really seen a scheme
that's perfect for him because he could
play so many different roles in just
about every single scheme but I kind of
go to the point that you just brought up
Melo where it's who do I want to see him
play with is what it comes down to for
me right now and you look at you know
how the draft is stacked of course
Jacksonville will have some town on the
defensive side of the ball
Cleveland will have miles
Gharib back i think the question for all
of us is where does Isiah Simmons go
because the argument a lot of people
make is well the value of the linebacker
has gone down in the league but the
guy's just not a linebacker but then you
also wonder how many of these
quarterbacks are gonna climb up and of
course chase young is penciled into the
top five so I think there's a lot of
good landing spots for him in the top 12
obviously I think still the Raiders have
to think about maybe even moving up for
him right now I think he's that much of
a perfect fit with them and I'll throw
one more out there we didn't talk about
this at the top of the show just because
of timing but Luke Kuechly retired the
Carolina Panthers need someone in little
the field quarters hover I mean they
want to keep Shaq Thompson on the
outside and we'll see what kind of
scheme Matt rule brings in when he picks
a defensive coordinator but I think
Carolina makes a lot of sense as well
basically if you can't find a fit for
him in your defense you need to change
your defense right Brian Goodwin in
their prime would you rather have Luke
Kuechly or Patrick Willis and he told me
not to be a biased Niners fan I still
would say Patrick Willis me too I'm
gonna say Luke Kuechly in their prime
and I do I get to assume that they're
both healthy because I think when
they're both healthy Luke Kuechly was
better I don't think so man I thought
Pat Willis was maybe the greatest
linebacker I'd seen play not named Ray
Lewis so I must be lower on Patrick
Willis than I think you are it's like I
do really like him but I would have him
after Kuechly
maybe I watched too much Luke Kuechly at
Boston we have Patrick wills over like
Bobby Wagner yeah okay I'd probably like
honestly have him right behind Ray Lewis
I really think Luke Kuechly is up there
you're right he's great guys I think
they're both top five middle linebackers
and I know that people are gonna throw
old linebackers at me and bi all 100 but
like yeah from the 2000s you're looking
at people that have played recently I
got have him over both of them how over
Brian Urlacher I don't know other
linebackers just do a position list
players that played after the VA
chess and cassette 1990 to 2020 right
yeah they're like a good radio station
that's what you get all right I didn't I
wasn't around here in the 80s I didn't
watch football in the 80s I'm not gonna
pretend yeah I barely did I was alive
for seven years now hey I'm currently
I've heard Lawrence Taylor was
exceptional I don't [ __ ] remember him
playing though there's a Mike Singletary
I don't really remember Mike Singletary
yeah I'm watching NFL Films
Joe Montana like I remember him as a
chief I don't really remember him as a
49er so you mean Joe Burrell
I don't get it that's who I mean he kind
of plays like Joe Wow
I'm not making the column the same cop
tweet it Chris martes Co if you were
starting a new NFL franchise which who
would you rather have as your franchise
quarterback the one you had concerns
about last year Daniel Jones were the
one you have concerns about this year
Justin Herbert give me just in a Herbert
every day and twice on Sunday between
those two because I still have Herbert
graded in the top 30 - hi Daniel Jones
like 56 overall I mean for a very long
time we thought Herbert was gonna come
out last year and I always had Herbert
ahead of Jones I had a lot of questions
with Jones I do think that he played
pretty well as a rookie but I think I'd
still roll the dice with Justin Herbert
the upside and the traits are just there
with Daniel Jones I don't know if you're
getting a guy that can go out and win
you games or if he can just come in and
manage games I would go with Herbert I
just like his traits better and I don't
think either you know neither will go
down his first-round quarterbacks for me
off Herbert in the second round this
year I had Daniel Jones in the top 70
last year so he was really inching
towards even the third round there for
me but quarterbacks always move up but
just to give a direct answer to the
question I still as an evaluator like
Justin Herbert better than I liked
Daniel Jones and we know a lot of time
left to tell this might be more
complicated because Haskins was the
third quarterback drafted but he was the
second quarterback
I think on all of our boards it was the
same would you rather have Justin
Herbert or join Haskins
I don't like askance I did not have him
second
I would rather have Herbert and than
Haskins so I would - actually I just was
like Gaskins quietly did some good
things at the end of the year with his
[ __ ] offense yeah yeah and I'm basing it
on pre-draft yes yes no not on what we
know now so it does kind of make you
like evaluate things a little bit
differently oh well when you put it like
it's a good game to play because you
look at things totally differently now
than you did then yeah
all right next question from our guy
Mason Whitlock if is there any way to
agos number one instead of jobber oh no
no I don't think no strong district I
love Mason you think he could yeah did
we think that what two years ago Baker
Mayfield was gonna go first over that's
fair
that's a good point we didn't but that
was the Cleveland is it likely no is it
a possibility you bet your ass well I
think you because it takes one team to
Bengals who had Joe Mixon on their board
yeah if the Bengals don't take Joe Mixon
he might go undrafted but they took him
in the second round so could I see a
scenario where - agos first overall yeah
I could I don't know if it'll happen but
I mean a lot of guys had to a ahead of
Joe burrow and if it's not for the
injury I think a lot of guys still have
to ahead of him which means if the
Bengals say you know what we like his
hip
it looks fine he's good we went to the
April workout he's throwing the ball
well we're gonna roll with a guy that
didn't work out they got three Scouts
they might drive one of them maybe they
need to hold it in like Nashville so the
Bengals can get there that's why I ran
Lance Scout I mean Joe Broz from two
hours from where he's from Athens it's
two hours away yeah definitely evaluated
know I so I love it when pics like this
happened like when LeBron went to the
Cavs or a Joe borough going back to Ohio
yeah it just makes too much sense and I
like that Home Coming right so I hope it
happens it's from Baltimore going to the
right skins makes so much sense
so I mean anything anything is possible
Joe Justin Herbert could go first
overall except for the Bucks
couldn't they didn't fly to Oregon to
watch him play all right Kyle Warren I
want to be clear sorry go ahead
I didn't move borough over - until the
injury yes became a problem so I didn't
know I love Joe borough but I just think
I
need to travel back in time and thought
people including all of us at some point
maybe not this exact comp but people
thought - it was the next coming of Drew
Brees I still have him comp - Drew Brees
yeah I do think I agree
I still love his healthy the way that he
throws with accuracy and touch all over
the field
if you can get him at a good workout
program and get him healthy because he
wasn't the Alabama which obviously isn't
concerned but I think that arm strength
is gonna improve I do think that he's a
smart quarterback and he did it for
three years in the SEC I still worry
about Joe burrow being a flash in the
pan I have him number two overall but I
really worry about was this a lot of you
know Joe Brady Clyde Edwards Hilaire the
three receivers wasn't just the perfect
storm of a lot of pretty average guys
working together or was this one
exceptional athlete in prospect I so I
will say this about - we could spend an
hour on this very conversation I had
burl above - before - his hip injury I
will always be concerned about the fact
that - it has had two ankle injuries and
now an injury so with burrow you worry
about easy a flash in the pan with - you
worry about easy
injury prone is it right I agree died in
college who get hurt often guess what
they get her often in the NFL yes so I
think there are legitimate concerns
about both guys but for me my concerns
about burrow or less because at least
know he's gonna be out if I'm making the
pick as the Bengals I'm going to take
Joe burrow
because I think with burrow you get at
minimum Andy Dalton for another five
years with Toa you might not get
anything you might get Marcus Mariota so
say if I'm yeah exactly if I'm picking I
would take burrow but is there a
situation where - it goes number one
yeah I do think there is the last
question and this is a short one for me
Patrick Chamberlain what's the best
football movie not named the program so
for me I'm going with Remember the
Titans it's good answer I don't know if
that I thought it was a very obvious
answer apparently it's not Connor
Friday Night Lights mm I love Remember
the Titans but and it's a great story
but I think Friday Night Lights is more
of a football movie so what I loved
spoiler alert here if you haven't seen
these two movies I absolutely love
at the end of Friday Night Lights they
[ __ ] lost cuz I write like other
movies or oh it's a feel-good great
story let's change the ending where they
win
nope they lost and they lost in the
movie so I'd and I was like hell yeah
this is accurate I'm on board with it so
Friday Night Lights would probably be
like third firm I hate Remember the
Titans because that's not the true story
they changed it to be more Disney so
that all the others that's my argument
yep here's mine
and you guys this is the last thing
we're gonna stay on the show draft day
[Laughter]
no I meant to write back to them like
Elite your account I respect how
confidently you just put this out to the
public they like drafting right like s3
draft nerds we don't like that much high
hopes for that movie it's the worst
movie of all time so my real answer is
any given Sunday because the end of that
spoiler alert
spoiler alert when he watched the pony
was like I'm gonna be the new head coach
in Arizona and I'm just I'm Willie
Beamen is my franchise quarterback Mike
[ __ ] drop by Al Pacino great great so
that is our show I have a question for
you guys is Jerry Maguire a football
movie oh man I think so I think so I
don't know like it could go both ways
yeah if it wouldn't be numbered it
wouldn't be number two for me I just
want to ask the question yeah I do love
Jamie I really don't like Renee
Zellweger no not at all but rod Tidwell
what a freakin he was so good yeah I
think we can classify the elbow movie
alright that is it that is our show come
see us and mobile [ __ ] Alabama Monday
night at 7:30 Wednesday night at 7:30
Tuesday night at some bar when we're
done eating handing out stick to
football hats it's gonna be a good time
thanks to Kenny Willa 'kiss went man
we're two for two on getting a pass
rushers from the Michigan area on stick
to football who will it be next big
white pass right right we love it all
right that is our show and go chiefs go
Niners we'll see you guys real soon